pas en chine on va regarder ces images
là ouais c'est quelque chose seulement
vous dire quand il pleut trop ça
fragilise beaucoup le sol alors c'est ce
qui est arrivé est heureusement ils s'en
sont bien sortis soyez rassuré les deux
piétons sont ok mais la chine n'est
frappé par de la pluie comme jamais
depuis 50 ans sa tâche est pas combien
de fin de semaine quand on parle de
pluies abondantes en chine juste pour
vous donner une idée le 7 juillet au
début du mois n'avait reçu 500 mm en 72
heures j'ai pas trouvé le chiffre total
depuis le début de ces précipitations là
mais ça me donne une bonne idée de
comment ça peut se passer une journée
donc presque pas de répit on estime à
tout près d'un million d'hectares de
culture de terres cultivables donc
demande hommage est complètement
détruite c'est pas compliqué on a aussi
24 millions de personnes dans 24
provinces qui sont touchées on parle de
200 personnes disparues ou décédée a
vraiment à une situation assez
exceptionnelle et c'est loin d'être
terminée on dit que la pluie va qu on va
continuer pendant un petit bout de temps